where facilities are designated by
gender students must be provided access
to gender specific facilities in
alignment
with their consistently asserted gender
identity so in other words kid goes to
school say it's a boy decides he
identifies as a girl now can use the
girls restroom okay that's their gender
identity how they define themselves they
do say that a student who's
uncomfortable using a shared facility
because of safety privacy or other
reason should upon request be provided
with a safe and non-stigmatizing
alternative
such as a single bathroom or a privacy
partition the problem with this is it
will be stigmatizing it will be
stigmatizing because if somebody comes
forward and we know this if a student
comes forward and says little girl comes
forward and says i'm uncomfortable
with someone with male
you know anatomy coming into the
bathroom that little girl is going to be
labeled you know there's something wrong
with her they're going to send her to
counseling the bullet point even says
that we're going to get to that in a
second other you know friends of hers
are going to say well why do you care
you know are you
bit the words bigoted you'd be surprised
they're going to be thrown around at
schools in front of little kids because
all these talking points come from
adults
they simmer down and suddenly now this
little girl who's uncomfortable is going
to be stigmatized i will guarantee you
it will happen 100
when i got to the bottom is where i got
a little twisted um and i teased that
just a moment ago some students may feel
uncomfortable with the transgender
student using the same sex specific
facility
right school administrators and
counseling staff members should work
with the students to address their
discomfort to foster understanding of
gender identity and to create a school
culture that respects and values all
students so they're going to put
a girl say i'm just using a girl as an
example because i think in a lot of
cases this is how it's gonna it's gonna
manifest little girls gonna say i'm
uncomfortable
someone with male anatomy coming into
the bathroom with me
and they're gonna send her to counseling
think about it think about you have
daughter i mean i'm just saying these
kids are just they're just expressing
stuff that's not comfortable for them
and now that kid's gonna have to be put
in counsel because if there's something
wrong with her as if there's something
wrong with her and this is the mean time
she's saying to herself i don't care how
old she is well this is how it's always
been this is like it doesn't seem right
to me i don't want to look at like a
little boy's stuff you know i mean you
know how kids are
it's always been like the girls team
they're they're used to a certain way of
things going down and they're not
they're not comfortable okay
the other thing that's interesting to me
is what's worded here this discomfort is
not a reason to deny access to the
transgender student
so they've decided now that that little
girl
her discomfort is not as important as
the discomfort that might occur
in the mind of a transgender student who
wasn't able to access the bathroom that
matched his or her gender identity the
way they identify
this is a problem it's going to be a
problem for parents i think it's going
to be a problem for kids i think it's
going to get deeply concerning
particularly when you're talking about
little girls i think really there's
going to be concerns about i don't know
different age brackets are you going to
want
your little girl remember this whole
debate popped up several years ago
you're going to want you know your
little girl's in
6th grade going into the bathroom with
an 8th grade you know based on biology
and based on anatomy boy who identifies
as a girl these are these are legitimate
concerns that people will have
um
they're valid concerns and again
listen
this is not a debate i'm going to say it
again because i i always get people say
oh you're a bigot you're this is not a
debate about adults and adult behavior
you're dealing with kids you're dealing
with schools who are pushing a certain
agenda
that's what we're talking about here
we're not talking about live and let
live we're not talking about any of that
parents you know at home weigh in are
you concerned about this pattern this is
not going to be the first school and
it's not going to be the last school are
you concerned about this pattern of
what's going on in schools as it relates
to your son your daughter please get in
the chat let us know i'll have to tell
you a check back um
i'm curious if this is something that's
concerning to you don't forget to
subscribe to hit like love graphic as
you know but please let me know
because i hear from parents all the time
that are worried about this and they're
not bigots and they're not trying to
hurt anybody but they are concerned
about their children who are localizing
discomfort and seem to have no
support within the school structure in
which to vocalize that sort of be sent
being sent to counseling and being
labeled you know i don't know something
wrong with her she's not adapting to 22
2022 culture that's where it's going
what advice would you give to anybody
who may be like parent-wise who is
agreeing with you what advice would you
give to
them talking to their kids like if this
was happening to hartley like how would
you speak partly in a sense of like
what's going on like how would you have
a conversation like that i think it
depends on the age of the child too like
parents have to be ready to have that
discussion um say they're in fifth grade
yeah you know you're gonna and that's
the thing these conversations are gonna
happen oftentimes earlier than you want
them to happen because these things are
happening in kindergarten now like
there's things that are changing rapidly
with very very young children so i think
parents are gonna have to just accept
that if you're sending your kids
particularly to public school
um
or in even private school settings in
many cases you're gonna have to have
these discussions early so i think you
have to be honest about what's going on
i think you have to allow your child to
express any discomfort i think you have
to be very involved
homeschooling is booming now for a
reason because people just trust these
systems
they distrust the systems they don't
they feel like they're being locked out
because they are as parents they don't
like that there's an agenda they don't
like that one kid you know his safe
space is more important than this kid's
safe space maybe they don't like that
there are safe spaces at all they don't
understand what's going on here with all
this woke stuff
but i think that i would probably have a
real conversation and say this is first
of all my kid would not be in a school
that you know had woke propaganda going
on in the school that would not be
happening
and parents also know know what's going
on in the school go up ask if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]